so meaning of crypto would have kept
going and going and going could it
possibly have been decades before Sam
Beekman freed and FTX works oh because
they were too Reckless I mean Madoff was
extremely buttoned down controlled
right uh very deliberate and actually in
the greater scheme of things
conservative you know Madoff didn't put
his name on a stadium did Madoff give a
billion dollars to politicians what
happens when a person with no money 24
months ago puts out a press release
saying I'm going to give a billion
dollars to the Democrats in the next two
years good point you don't think your
head down wasn't looking for headlines
but SPF was searching for headlines
where he was just splashing money around
like it was free